Let's spend a little time just settling on the breath.
developing metta in the particular.
Bring to mind and into your heart a benefactor.
Bring to mind and into your heart all those who are near and dear to you.
Bring to mind and into your heart friends, workmates, even good acquaintances.
Bring to mind and into your heart a neutral person.
turn the stream of goodwill towards ourselves.
bringing to mind and into that heart of goodwill someone whom we find difficult, remembering that here lies the gateway to universal, unconditional love.
having developed our metta in the particular.
Let us radiate it outwards, first of all, to all those who are here with us now.
to all those in this district, whether they live wholesome or unwholesome lives.
to all those in our country.
To all who live in Europe,
to all people on earth.
Offering Metta to all beings in the six directions.
All beings before us.
all beings behind us.
All beings to our left.
all beings to our right.
all beings below us.
all beings above us.
and to all beings in all directions.